At this point, based on bowel movements, my tumor is still restricting things, not much
improvement there, but it, but we won't know until the next MRI to help.
I believe your program is working, certainly, situation is slightly better with no additional
spread, and more importantly, I feel generally good, though I do feel restrictions in the colon.
I do have bone and bone in my left hip, that is not related to the cancer, and it appears
that no hip replacement surgery will be appropriate until some sort of alopathic intervention takes
place or the tumor is gone. So I think this person is being restricted to do any type of hip
replacement surgery until he agrees to do colon surgery or something. I think that's the situation.
At your suggestion, I investigated the prolo therapy as well as stem cell therapy,
but the doctor said I was not a candidate after seeing the x-rays. So that's unfortunate,
so it must be pretty bad. So stem cell therapy can be really beneficial, but if you're really,
really bone on bone, then it's just, it's just may not work at all. The other thing that you could,
I will say that you that I know people have had success with is ozone injections. So there is a
rogue doctor in Minnesota. I think she is still doing it, is doing ozone injections, and it was really
for people with disc issues and bone on bone issues, because she was injecting ozone right into the
site. So you may find somebody locally that's doing that. Look up doctors who are doing ozone,
and I think there was mixed benefits and I can't think this is, you know, a serious condition with
its bone on bone is a chance that that's going to help us. Probably not really great, but it can get
you through, for sure. Back to a question on the blog. I'm really sorry. I'm not asking my questions,
right? I guess what function, what is the function of homocysteine? What damage is done when it's high?
How does it affect detox pathways to the growth? Homocysteine does not affect to the growth,
does not affect detox pathways. Homocysteine can damage your artery, so you don't want to have
high homocysteine for a long time, because you can etch your arteries. That's the whole reason why
you want to decrease homocysteine. So, and you can look up homocysteine there, maybe other, you know,
I have to look it up and see what other functions homocysteine, you know, understand everything in your
body, all your metabolites are none of them are just all bad, you know, they serve a good function,
but in excess they conserve a bad function, it's all about balance.